wir schauen mal nach vorne denn Martin
Reichert spricht schon
Landesvorsitzender von Sachsen-Anhalt
und das wollen wir natürlich nicht
verpassen
Erfolge haben beim politischen
Establishment eine Welle von Hass und
Hetze ausgelegt eine Welle liebe Freunde
die selbst unsere in vielen stürmen
erprobte Partei bisher noch nicht erlebt
hat aber eines kann man von hier aus
auch sagen diese Welle der Hass und des
Hasses unter Hetze die wird nicht den
etabl
ierten sondern die Menschen im Lande
erkennen diese Welle ist eine Welle die
das Volk ergreift eine Welle die uns
nach vorne fühlt und die uns einen Sieg
bei der Europawahl und bei den Wahlen in
diesem Jahr Herr bescheren wird liebe
Freunde
[Applaus]
und davor davor hat man Angst der
Präsident des wohl am weitesten
degenerierten sogenannten
Verfassungsschutzes Kramer aus Thüringen
nannte große Teile unserer Wähler
braunen Bodensatz und der gescheiterte
ehemalige ostbeauftragte wanderwitz
forderte ein Verbot unserer
demokratischen Partei das ist eine polit
Bundesbank grott Erklärung das ist einer
Demokratie unwürdig und das zeigt den
Geist der Altparteien und wir alleine
sind die die dem entgegenstellen liebe
Freunde
aber anders als die Altparteien wird uns
eins gelingen wir werden diese
widerliche antidemokratische
anti-deutsche und volksfeindliche Hetze
auf diesem Parteitag und an diesem
Wochenende inhaltlich Stellen liebe
Freunde denn wir haben Inhalte die
anderen haben keine
[Applaus]
wir werden hier einen Parteitag abhalten
der wichtige Weichen stellt einen
Parteitag der auch vom äußeren Ambiente
her in einem unter einem guten Stern
steht denn es ist ein Parteitag wenn wir
uns die Gegendemonstrationen angucken
tausende haben sie angekündigt ein
kleines Häuflein unentwegter linker
Spinner stört uns ein wenig aber wir
schreiten daran vorbei lasst sie wählen
die AFD Karawane zieht weiter
und darum können wir hier auch heute
eines sagen von diesem Parteitag und von
diesem Wochenende und auch vom kommenden
Wochenende wird eine Listenwahl für das
Europaparlament ausgehen die wir unter
das Motto stellen können europa wir
kommen um Deutschland zu retten liebe
Freunde
ja und wir hier in Sachsen-Anhalt wir
dürfen mit Stolz sagen dass wir nicht
zum ersten Mal Ausgangspunkt eines
beispiellosen Siegeszuges unsere AFD
sind 2016 haben wir mit
24,3%. das erste Mal ein machtvolles
Zeichen gesetzt dass uns in
Sachsen-Anhalt zu einer Positionierung
brachte die heute die gesamte AFD für
sich in Anspruch nehmen kann und muss
wir sind Volkspartei liebe Freunde
und mit der Gewissheit die einzige echte
deutsche Volkspartei zu sein werden wir
an diesem und am nächsten Wochenende die
Weichen für einen fulminanten
europawahlkampfstellen unsere
europa-kandidaten werden Garanten für
eine Politik sein die getragen ist von
einer tief empfundenen Achtung für alle
europäischen Völker und diese tief
empfundene Achtung sie erweckt uns aus
dem reinen Herzen unserer Partei deren
dessen höchstes Gut die Liebe zum
eigenen Volk und die Liebe zur eigenen
Nation ist und das Können und das können
nur wir als AFD
denn nur denn nur wer die Liebe zur
eigenen Nation kennt kann glaubhaft die
Liebe anderer Völker und Nationen zu
sich selbst anerkennen und achten diese
Emotion diese emotionale Bindung
unterscheidet die Patrioten Europas von
globalistischen Mehrwert Fetischisten
und linken Hetzern denen alle Nationen
Europas verhasst sind und die sie
deshalb in einer bürgerfeindlichen EU
auflösen wollen und darum werden auch
die europäischen Patrioten immer stärker
und diese Europawahl wird die Europawahl
des Patriotismus in Europa
[Applaus]
und den auflösungsbestrebungen die gegen
die europäischen Nationen gerichtet sind
erteilen wir eine klare Absage unser
Europa ist ein Europa souveräner
Nationen und um es mit schade Gold zu
sagen ein Europa der Vaterländer liebe
Freunde
und im Interesse der Freiheit der Völker
Europas sagen wir ganz besonders jenen
politischen Kräften den politischen
Kampf an die mit verkommenen
Protagonisten wie Robert Habeck
Vaterlandsliebe stets zum Kotzen fanden
solche deutschlandhasser und Nationen
Verächter gehören in keine Regierung
liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
denn denn und das gilt es hier auch zu
beachten solche linksgrüne Missachtung
der Nationen ist ja nicht nur eine
Missachtung der deutschen Nation sondern
es ist eine Missachtung aller Völker
Europas und es ist eine Verachtung der
ganzen Menschheit und so etwas darf nie
wieder eine steuergröße deutscher
Politik werden liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
und darum
begehen wir gemeinsam diesen Parteitag
mit unserem unverbrüchlichen Bekenntnis
zur Freiheit Bürgerrechten und
Demokratie in diesem Sinne liebe Freunde
kämpfen wir gegen linksgrünen
Totalitarismus und seine
pseudokonservativen Steigbügelhalter
kämpfen wir politisch für die Freiheit
der Völker Europas kämpfen wir politisch
für ein Deutschland und ein Europa das
auch kommende Generationen noch als
blühende Heimat unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder vorfinden können in diesem
Sinne wünsche ich uns ein ruhigen und
gelungenen Parteitag vielen Dank
[Musik]
vielen Dank
das
landesmuster
2017 ist ja auch Mitglied des Deutschen
Bundestags